The Story begins in a crowded train
station hundreds of passengers are
bustling to get inside a train among
which is a father named Zhang he has
come along with his little son and
teenage daughter but before he boards
the train something unusual happens the
station staff rushes to stop a
mysterious train from entering the
station because it's not supposed to be
there after the second train stops
everyone goes to check on it to their
horror when they open one of the
compartments a load of dead bodies and
rats pour out of it Zhang also sees the
horrific scene and becomes worried that
something bad must be going on as he
continues peeking through the window a
thug picks a fight with him claiming
that he is in his seat Zhang apologizes
for the inconvenience but the thug
doesn't stop bullying him and his
daughter way fortunately before things
can escalate a Good Samaritan by the
name of du Shan intervenes and escorts
the father-daughter Duo from there after
the minor incident way thanks Shan for
helping them out while Zhang starts
wandering around the train just then the
other passengers hear a strange sound
from the ceiling and the camera Zooms in
to show that the ceiling is infested
with a herd of rats in the next
compartment that houses Elite people
Zhang unexpectedly sees his long-lost
daughter Ling with her husband who is
now an Army Major he angrily approaches
her claiming that it took him years to
find her however when he starts forcing
Lang to come with him the nearby army
officers take control of Zhang her
husband inquires if she knows the man to
which Ling lies that she doesn't as a
result Zhang is taken to a dark room and
chained to His Hands by the officers he
is being punished for the attempted
assault on the Major's wife just then
the officers and Zhang see another man
who is Chained in a corner one of the
officers goes to check on him but the
man is shaking weirdly when he turns it
is revealed that he has been bitten by
the deadly rats suddenly The Vicious
rodents swarm the room and start
crawling over the officers meanwhile
Zhang's son is attracted by a weird
sound and follows it he soon realizes
that something is moving under a cloth
and when he slowly removes it it only
turns out to be a cat on the lookout for
something inside another compartment a
woman Hears A squawking sound from the
ceiling and becomes annoyed hence she
asks her husband to do something about
it obliging her request the man brings
out a stick and starts banging on the
roof of the train unfortunately he
knocks open a small ventilator from
which thousands of rats start pouring
inside in no time they attack all the
passengers and finish them off meanwhile
the major and the Train's Captain catch
wind of the attack so they urge their
people to take off immediately it
appears as if they are well aware about
what's going on after packing their
belongings Ling manages to escape to a
safe compartment with her husband
elsewhere inside the dark room Zhang
watches in horror as all the army
officers are devoured right in front of
his eyes terrified that he is next Zhang
starts saying his final prayers but even
after waiting for a while nothing
happens this is when he realizes that
the rats are afraid of sunlight hence he
quickly grabs the key to his chain that
is lying on the floor and unlocks
himself however once he is outside Zhang
sees that the compartment is full of
dead bodies there are also rats crawling
all over the floor but fortunately he
slowly climbs above the seats and
manages to escape after reaching the
next compartment Zhang warns the
passengers about the deadly rats but the
people just make fun of him they assume
that he is hallucinating and on drugs
but because of the insults Zhang takes
his daughter away and moves to the next
compartment just then an injured man
arrives at the back door of the previous
compartment and thuds dead on the ground
the other passengers who have now become
anxious see something moving under the
man's cloth and it turns out to be a rat
soon enough thousands of rats break
through the door and attack everyone on
site Shan tries his best to escort as
many people as he can into the next
compartment but seeing the rats getting
closer he closes the door at the same
time the officers also lock the other
compartments behind them leaving the
passengers on one side to die Lange who
is worried about her family tries to
convince her husband to open the door
but he does not listen now Zhang his
children Shan and another guy are
trapped in the compartment with nowhere
to escape to make matters worse
thousands of rats have ganged up and are
attempting to break the door that
separates them from the humans it
appears as if our protagonists have
reached their Doom but just then Shan
finds a way to get out through the
ceiling Zhang and his children are also
pulled out of the compartment but the
Last Passenger remains unfortunately it
is too late for him as the rodents burst
out of the door and kill him meanwhile
due to the increasing danger the captain
of the train comes up with a plan to
disconnect the latter carriages this is
the section where Zhang his family and
hundreds of other people are residing
Ling is totally against the plan but the
major once again disregards her wishes
and detaches the carriages Shan who
notices The Carriage is splitting
immediately jumps to the first half of
the train and manages to save away as
well but when it is Zhang and his son's
turn to jump the train starts blasting
from the back thankfully at the last
second the father-son duo takes a leap
of faith and Shan manages to catch them
after a while as Ling and the other
passengers are mourning the loss of
their family members Zhang and the group
arrive at their compartment Ling is
relieved to see her family alive but due
to her bad password with her father she
doesn't approach them in the next scene
one of the passengers suddenly Falls
unconscious on the floor it is revealed
that he has been bitten by the rodents
and is now infected because of this the
officers decide to separate the infected
ones and keep them quarantined Zhang
anxiously checks his children to make
sure that they are fine but when he
notices that his son has been bitten he
is devastated realizing that his son
doesn't have much time Zhang reveals to
the passengers that he works in the
health department and a few days ago he
was assigned to get medicine that can
reduce the infection of the rodents the
medicine is stored in a hospital which
is in the next District however the
captain doesn't want to make any stops
since the rodents are too dangerous and
they will just be wasting time this
divides the people into two groups and
during the commotion a thug brings it a
gun and keeps the captain hostage he
then demands that they will be stopping
by as everyone needs medicine at the
moment left with no choice the captain
agrees after an hour the train arrives
at the district and Zhang Wei Shan and
three other passengers volunteer for the
mission the train driver gives them two
hours to get back to the station he
tells them that once the time exceeds
the train must depart considering the
safety of the other passengers soon the
group arrives at a town but it has been
completely destroyed moving ahead they
see a pile of dead bodies laying all
over the street the group has no choice
but to walk over these bodies to reach
the hospital after crossing the corpses
they see a herd of rats ready to Feast
on whatever comes their way fortunately
they are also hiding from sunlight and
when Zhang notices this He suggests his
group walk on top of the nearby pipes
sadly a guy loses his grip and slips
down Zhang and the others can only watch
as the man is quickly devoured by the
rodents meanwhile a man from the town
gets on the train and informs the
passengers that the rats are scared of
the daylight but they can be more
dangerous and deadly during the night
learning this the passengers demand to
return to the train and flee while they
can suddenly dark clouds start taking
over the town covering the sunlight this
makes the rodents come out from the
shadows and go after Zhang and his group
sadly another man loses his life when he
slips down the rest of the group somehow
makes it to the hospital but Shan
injures his leg in the process inside
they are attacked by a person but Zhang
immediately calms him saying that they
are here for the medicine and mean no
harm hearing this the man introduces
himself as the caretaker of the place
and leads the group to the hospital
Warehouse along the way they come across
millions of rats squeaking crawling and
waiting for their next prey the group
then uses fire to scare away the rodents
back in the Train the passengers along
with the Thugs who still have the
captain and his men hostage start to
think that the rescue team will not
return or they are already dead hence
they decide to start the train but this
only causes a fight as some people are
still hopeful that Zhang and his group
will return with the medicine meanwhile
an old lady who is tired of all the
commotion heads to the front door and
opens it with this thousands of rats
come inside and attack the passengers
Ling who is with her brother can do
nothing but watch from a nearby
compartment in the warehouse Zhang and
the others enter a hall where they they
see a large nest of rats Zhang decides
to go alone inside and retrieve the
medicine but after he gets the medicine
box and prepares to return the furniture
beneath him breaks somehow he manages to
hold on and at the same time the
caretaker arrives and asks Zhang to give
him the box but as soon as he gets it he
hurries outside and locks the group in
the hall the caretaker then explains
that he will sell the medicine in order
to improve his financial condition dude
what is money going to buy you at a time
like this soon after the large nest of
rats starts dispersing unleashing
millions of rodents all around the hall
fortunately the group manages to break
down the door and escape from the
warehouse they then join the traitor who
locked them in the hall but it turns out
that his son and wife died while he was
away while he is mourning Zhang and the
group silently grabbed the medicine box
and hurry outside they then get inside a
parked Jeep and drive away as the swarm
of rats dangerously chases them from
behind suddenly the dark clouds clear
and there is sunlight once again this
makes the rodents hide away in the dark
thus the group makes it out of the Town
alive however once they reach the train
they see the deceased bodies of the
passengers lying around assuming that
their family members have been killed
Zhang and the others start crying but
just then Ling and some officers come
out of their compartment much to
everyone's Delight unfortunately their
happy moment is cut short when the
weather once again changes as dark
clouds hover above the town the swarm of
rats also gets out of the dark and heads
towards the train suddenly one of the
officers snatches the medicine box from
Zhang and hits him in the head bitten
all over his body by the rats the
officer then tries running away but Shan
stops him and retrieves the medicine
which he passes back to Zhang by this
time the rats have almost arrived so the
entire group hurries back inside the
train sadly Shan fails to get back
because of the injury he sustained
earlier before being devoured by the
rodents he calls way and confesses his
feelings for her making his demise even
more tragic that was kinda selfish after
a while Zhang starts injecting the
medicine into the infected ones and
things finally start getting better
however the train suddenly stops and the
passengers learn that there is a
blockade on the track ahead Zhang
immediately ushers his fellow passengers
to clear the path together but nobody
wants to risk their lives by going
outside having no choice Zhang goes
outside alone and tries to move the
large Carriage seeing his determination
his daughter way and soon the rest of
the passengers also join him at the same
time one of the thugs straps himself
with explosives and lures the rats when
they swarm him he sacrifices himself and
kills the rats giving the passengers
ample time to remove the blockade this
heroic act by the thug encourages the
passengers even more and they finally
manage to move the carriage but soon
after the train starts they realize that
the current path is leading to a dead
end hence Zhang has to manually execute
the handle to change the track but when
he gets the job done and attempts to
board the train he realizes that the
tracks have again changed this is
because the handle is broken because of
this Zhang has to hold it himself until
the train changes its track once he
completes the the task he runs after the
train as a swarm of rats follows him
from behind unfortunately as he is about
to get inside he falls down and hurts
himself by this time the rats are too
near for him to escape the final scene
of the movie shows Ling and way wailing
for their father since they know he
cannot make it to the train Zhang is
soon Infested by the rats but he dies in
relief knowing that he was able to save
his children that was the best damn DLC
for a plague tale I've ever seen
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching